that's why this is a classic case of me
sitting around nothing really to do so I
go through Netflix and the founders on
there and I was like I want to watch
that so I watched it and was immediately
met with that feeling of I got to do a
video on this so let's talk about it the
founder so the founder is the story of
Ray Kroc that's right in the 50s Ray
Kroc created McDonald he gave us fast
food creating an empire the rest is
history
or maybe that's not how it went down
that's what this movies about this movie
is the story of the beginning of
McDonald's as we don't know it it stars
Michael Keaton is Ray Kroc we all love
Michael Keaton we all know he does a
good job in this movie and in the
beginning this movie does a good job at
getting you on Ray Kroc side he's a
struggling salesman he wants to make
money he just needs a good idea when a
good idea comes to him you're like yeah
man do it work with these guys and
create something big create something
good and then that abort you have to
reflect to be like am i rooting for the
villain oh god these guys being the
McDonald's brothers that's right these
brothers owned a restaurant called
McDonald played by John Carroll Lynch
and Nick Offerman they were great and
it's such a fast efficient way of making
good food Kroc was just blown away he's
like you guys need to franchise this
thing and as it's on the social network
well there we go and you can totally see
these brothers given their personalities
like I could see you guys going into
business together
I could see you guys making a really
good business you got the financially
efficient business minded one you got
the one who just wants to do good by the
people in this community I love that
more than that I love movies about
entrepreneurialism movies about growing
something me straight out of Compton did
that social network did that heck
nightcrawler did that what all of these
stories have in common is someone gets
screwed over when there is someone who
just completely wants to take over the
world in some way shape or form or at
least take over their world doesn't
change the fact that I'm always
interested in the mind of someone like
that then that you have two sides of it
you have Ray Kroc side and the
McDonald's brothers side McDonald's
brothers I feel like I identify more
with them every piece of paper or
contract I've ever signed to work with
someone in the YouTube space I'm always
like is this the moment where the biopic
of my life becomes the biopic of their
lives and I'm just a footnote I'm a side
character and the shoulders they stand
on to get what they want while I'm left
in the dust
it is a concerning thing it's like every
time you sign a contract or go into
business with someone you like and I
into business with the devil that's the
question so far been pretty lucky and
the more crock gets the more he wants
when you're going into business with a
couple of brothers you know like the
family restaurant you know someone's
going to get hoes man Laura Dern's in
the movie she's not in the movie much
you feel like she's in the movie because
well Ray Kroc had a wife this is the
story of him so obviously they need to
cast the wife but she really does feel
like she's in the background really
she's there to show when Ray Kroc moving
forward he's leaving everything behind
including her and I really didn't feel
like this movie could have been about
ten minutes shorter near the middle of
this movie feels like our eyes winding
down we're not winding down you're
seeing him do stuff but you get the
point
he made contacts the business of growing
somewhere around there between the
middle and the end they could have
shaved about ten minutes off because and
then the founder was great I love
Michael Keaton's betrayal the supporting
cast is awesome the purity of the
McDonald's brothers and what they wanted
and they all go into business together
and you're like you all can work
together fine right really this is a
story that you probably could have seen
on a documentary but sometimes when you
see a story like that you're like why
hasn't this been made into a movie this
story lends itself to be a movie and it
was done very well you guys want an
interesting biopic of the founding of
McDonald's of the story you might not
have heard before certainly a good one I
will say the founder is definitely worth
watching it definitely worth buying on
blu-ray like next time you're watching
Shark Tank you're going to look at
everyone really all right who screwed
you over right guys - the founder have
you seen it what did you think about or
what's an entrepreneurial movie that you
like where someone ultimately screws
someone over maybe not a lot of people
know about the movie I'd like to know
about it so whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]